happy black friday we love toys we're
still on for pancakes tonight
chris you're on reg for the night we're
short staff wait up
i'm emmett you ever work retail before
no well there's no day more harmful to
retail workers than this day
oh what do we love toys good job
places everyone three
two go baby go flat friday
thank you very much happy holidays
[Applause]
the f
there is something wrong with the
shoppers
oh we got to do something we're one hour
into black friday and we're escorting
customers away from the store
no no
was that the new guy
our shoppers are going crazy whatever
you do don't let them gather they're
building something
at this point we're just in their way
we're gonna have to fight
i don't think this night can get any
worse
does anybody else just think that's
funny
i told you they never die
we have to make a run for it
exactly black friday is over
chucky says we're all going to die back
up
and homie the stockings all filled up at
last
curations of all the glitter silver and
gold i love it here the police are here
thank god
right here [ __ ]
you